non mais tu sais combien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
secondes quand on était à nrj 12 la
nouvelle patronne nrj12 à l'époque
trouver benoît un petit peu vulgaire et
vu benoît avait déclaré dans un journal
je me suis fait augmenter le sexe et je
suis convoqué dans le bureau j'anime
elle m'a ôté et elle me dit enfin c'est
incroyable c'est vulgaire pour la chaîne
je veux parler à ce gamin je passe bien
je descends le diagnostic prévient la
nouvelle patronne compagnie veux te
parler mais je n'ai pas les rues d'ici
et et dont la lironde nos bureaux et la
nouvelle patronne comment elle s'appelle
la patronne prend le magazine ou via les
marques et je me suis fait grossir le
sexe et elle lui dit pourquoi ça
pourquoi et benoît répond ben j'ai
envoyé une plus grosse que je
sais quoi j'ai pas vraiment pété un
plomb mais ça c'est arrivé vraiment
comme une vague soudaine n'était pas du
tout prévu à la célébrité moi je le
faisais pour l'argent je m'attendais pas
une suite comme ça tout de suite gérard
louvin un monstre de la télé on
m'apprend que jérôme est un préau
énergie comme tu l'as dit et tout est là
tout va très très vite et je suis
spectateur c'est à dire que je deviens
transparent de moi même c'est à dire que
je suis un produit
marketing par les chaînes télé par tf1
par ça et du coup je deviens vraiment
une poupée qu'on met à droite à gauche
et je m'oublie totalement et je deviens
la caricature de moi même c'est à dire
j'étais quand même un personnage haut en
couleur bella du coup ne sachant pas
vraiment comment exercer cette nouvelle
profession j'en rajoute je rajoute je
rajoute pour le protéger comme une
armure si tu veux et donc du coup ça a
marché finalement pas ce que je fais
huit ans sur nrj 12 au final ce n'était
pas le vrai moi c'est à dire que je me
suis fait passer pour quelqu'un d'autre
encore plus haut en couleurs que je
n'étais pour pouvoir exister de me
défendre sony s'était pas dès le début
parce que là quand tu vois ta
présentation par exemple est-ce que
avant de fêter sans attendre actuel est
en fait dès l'instant où tu as commencé
tu as finalement tiré le trait de ce que
tu étais illinois avant cet excentrique
exact enfin si j'ai toujours était
excentrique que la présentation là tu
mets les talons étoiles or il à la
production m'a demandé de mettre des
talons de me balader dans les champs à
côté des vaches avec des talons et ou
bien sûr j'avais des petites échelles
moitié faut faire le con le samedi soir
avec mes amis je vais pas chercher le
pantalon soit c'est énorme c'est pas
prêt si bien que quand j'ai fait le
casting tf1 ne voulait pas de moi et
endemol voulait de moi parce que j'ai
faim disait que c'était trop la folle
furieuse data du salon coiffure et tout
ce que j'étais ou entre guillemets on
est du coup très fade et nous on prend
pas le dossier il est trop lourd pour la
ménagère de tf1 pour secret story et
endemol a dit il nous faut absolument
gamin il nous faut il nous faut et du
coup ils n'ont pas pris de risque qui
m'ont mis sur internet quelques jours
avant six classes d'horizon et s'il doit
rentrer c'est le public qui choisira le
même entrain de vous personne s'est
mouillé et après faire je suis sorti
andy
rihs mais c'est moi qui t'ai trouvé
que je devrais pas le dire parce que
c'est nous regardaient très peu de
colère mais afida turner a joué dans mon
bureau en libye mais je sais faire je
vais faire un dîner presque parfait les
aidants sont explosés
de showtime ils savent que quand à afida
cartonne donc m6 m'a appelé m'a dit nafi
là on te veux dans l'année presque
parfaite combien tu veux je les 150 mire
vous dites quoi cent cinquante mille
dollars us avec un virement et j'ai dit
il connut quoi ils m'ont dit non mais
t'as fait quoi j'ai fait des missions et
quand tu sais combien 500 euros
[Applaudissements]
effectivement vous avez une belle photo
la
fed allait frapper des gens d'accord
pour dire la vérité ça m'est arrivé ça
jamais été diffusé mais effectivement il
ya eu ou non il ya un studio c'est
normal mais non entre moi et je me
défonce à ses vrais ados ouais
submergé par la colère harmos se jette
sur son marteau et façades
j'ai lu quelques-uns qui était même
entraîner s'étaient entraînés ils
voulaient en découdre avec mon attention
bien sûr et a gagné à chaque fois je
suis pas tout dire arrête toi tu as
perdu une fois jamais jamais non je me
livrais troisième g14 end à tekoa
devront être india 4e dan de quoi donc
un coup d'essai c'est hallucinant
facilement en plus non seulement ils
parlent mal mais en plus certains ont eu
des gestes très déplacé en ma présence
mais vraiment qui se fait balayer au sol
là nous suppliaient de montrer les
images qu'on n'a pas le droit c'est
interdit on le sait et c'est de la
violence par intérim donc là le gamin
part directement foyer donc on n'a
jamais pu montrer ce genre d'imagés
pourtant les bars ont signé pour ça
qu'en même temps tu restais à la famille
à l'époque c'était toujours à tf1 douze
jours pourquoi la star ac n'a pas pris
toit pour gérer tous les gamins landes
en esata moi je pense que je sais
pourquoi cette f1 ouais mais ça oui je
suis parti un peu pas fâchés mais j'ai
quitté tf1 à l'époque on est en plein de
signatures de contrats s'est pas
entendus sur les contrats alors je pense
que je vais mal fait je suis parti comme
ça j'aurais peut-être pas dû donc
d'ailleurs je m'en excuse auprès de la
chaîne parce que c'est quand même grâce
à eux aujourd'hui j'en suis là c'est
systématiquement dans des familles
extrêmement modeste mais tous ou parfois
c'était des gens le père est avocat vous
n'êtes pas mieux à deux et en mer dubawi
on a eu des familles avec d'un chef
d'entreprise très riche par ross en
belgique aux musiques en belgique
c'est muscu tout le temps tout l'argent
en permanence à l'actif de pion dans
cinquante deux ans quand même déjà mais
on compte deux frères sas et son
commerce
mais avec un garde du corps dos des cas
avec la plus volée tu vois
quatre soirées tout le monde ne supporte
pas la célébrité est ta saison c'était
avec fx françois xavier était très aimée
avec lui mais on sait que pour soi
xavier s'est suicidé s'est jeté sous une
voiture on passe pas d'image tout ça on
n'a pas envie mais qu'est-ce que ça ça
t'a inspiré après ce que tu t'es dit
justement que vous étiez pas assez
préparée est ce que tu t'es taton a
voulu à quelqu'un à la prod est ce que
tu feras qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que
ça dit de cette génération bas elle fixe
était quelqu'un qui déjà avait une
faiblesse avant de rentrer dans le jeu
c'est à dire qu'il était déjà très jeune
déjà voilà il avait des problèmes de
drogue avant de rentrer dans l'émission
voilà il était issu d'une famille quand
même très aisés qui donc a fait ce qu'il
pouvait mais voilà dans un milieu où il
avait accès à plus facilement à des gens
de déviance et je pense que la notoriété
l'a pas aidé peut-être avoir une
reconnaissance dans sa famille voilà
c'était une reconnaissance qu'il avait
besoin elle fixe enfin voila il manque
beaucoup et c'est vrai que quand il ya
eu la plus grosse la lumière s'est
arrêtée parce qu'avec cette émission
ensuite qui est parti qui a pas marché
du tout par nous allons y arriver chaque
année quand la lumière s'est un peu
arrêté sur lui l'a très mal vécu c'est
dans ces moments qu'on se dit est-ce que
c'est pas dans ces moments où l'appareil
pour loana ou quand elles lumière
s'arrête c'est là où il faudrait
peut-être soutenir ceux qui sont les
plus faibles la lumière s'arrête
forcément au bout d'un moment c'est pour
ça qu'on court vite à faire plein de
projets on sort d'une émission comme ça
c'est ce que j'ai fais d'ailleurs après
quand on est trop jeune et quand on fait
ce genre d'émission c'est sûr que c'est
difficile après de se relever et de se
dire que non mais c'est pas la vraie vie
quand la neige avait 25 ans 26 en quoi
la feci crête vont elles étaient déjà
plus mature moi j'avais 26 ans quand je
suis entré dans le sucre est on sait que
la vraie vie c'est pas la célébrité on
sait que moi à chaque fois que je
faisais mais tout ce que j'ai fait après
secrète pour moi c'était du jeu j'ai
jamais rien pris au sérieux et encore
aujourd'hui mais la célébrité c'est pour
de faux pour moi en fait et nuit il a
vraiment cru que les gens qu'il aimait
les musulmans et les gens qui ne le
regardait plus nenê mais plus tu vois
donc c'était un peu l'enfant maudit
compliqué c'est de faire voilà de se
faire remarquer pour son lait